هذا الرجل ليس مريضا ولا يعاني من الام
حلت به انه في حاله روحانيه عميقه بعد ان
فرغ للتو من دق وشم مقدس على جسده وشوم
غريبه لنمور وتماسيح وثعابين لكنها ستحميه
من السحر والارواح الشريره حسب ما يعتقد
هنا تايلاند وتحديدا منطقه
الواقعه على بعد نحو 80 كيلومترا من
بانكوك حيث يقام مهرجان سنوي يتوافد اليه
الاف البوذيين في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
الاولى من شهر مارس ليحصلوا على وشم جديد
او يجدد وشوما قديمه يطلقون عليها اسم
ساكيانت ويعتقدون انها تحميهم من السحر
وتمنحهم القوه والحظ السعيد الرهبان هنا
يتولون مهمه دق الوشوش بواسطه عصي
الخيزران او الابر المعدنيه الطويله
حاولوا ايادي بعض الاتباع الى مخالب نمر
واخرون تحولوا الى تماسيح فيما اختارت فئه
اخرى وشوم القرد هانومان المقدس لدى
البوذيين اجواء وطقوس غريبه يؤدي فيها
الحاضرون حركات ورقصات مختلفه فمن حصل على
وشم النمر يجسد النمر وسلوكه اما اولئك
الذين حصلوا على وشم التماسيح والثعابين
فيرقدون ويتحركون على الارض ويميل البعض
الاخر الى تفريغ كميات وفيره من الطاقه
بصراخ طويل او عويل
اسطوره هذه الوشوم تقول ان القرويين هناك
كانوا يتعرضون بكثره لهجمات من النمور
والتماسيح والحيوانات البريه الاخرى
فلجاوا الى احد الرهبان الذي وصف لهم
تعويذه على شكل وشم تحميهم من هجمات
الحيوانات ويقال ايضا ان وشوم ساكيانت
كانت تدق على اجساد المحاربين لحمايتهم
خلال المعارك
هدى
المهرجان سابقا كان يقتصر على سكان
المنطقه لكن خلال السنوات الاخيره بات يجد
اقبالا واسعا في صفوف السياح الاجانب
خصوصا بعد ان قصدت الممثله الشهيره
انجلينا جولي المكان وحصدت على بعض من
وشوش